welcome to this video playing Russ
Parikh Nick from the Netherlands does he
have a name let's check it
yes burger ringing phone rings um
Groningen feeder to 350 hmm yeah play in
the Netherlands for for four years and
they're still really respectable players
that I don't know one of them obviously
so Roy exchange dribble
what could a play I can play this Bishop
g4 gambit line I don't know it too well
but let's try that age three you go here
and give up the pawn after g4 that is
okay c3 is not not a common booth but
not a logical of course
interesting
maybe creed III as strange as it looks
like energy but then he can play G form
nope don't do that
should I play f6 it's probably not too
bad
but it's not a move that I'd like to
play and so let's develop let's develop
you on d4 I still have a choice
I forgot I can take off these six I
wanted to play Bishop f3 and Queen e5
but Bishop I have 386 yeah well whatever
I need to do it anyway it is six Bishop
f1 I mean it's not not a big problem
I think it's not a particularly great
position for me but that's not the
position that there should be terribly
bad okay I'll get this back we had to
put the bishop now this is in fact
interesting yeah maybe all the way back
yeah
maybe right a slightly better possible
it's possible wait let's so let's
consider this for a moment
should I take with the night
I could think with the king okay let's
let's try to speed up a bit yeah we can
try to - double
double on the D phone I'm trying Bishop
f7 and night g6 - maybe night C for a
five I know we have not covered that
sorry I'm covering that but 96 King e7
roopd a this is maybe okay maybe his
heading is heading for a fire
yeah this is not too great but still
families of it
well why does certainty better I'm not
sure how he really makes any headway
oh no I'm not sure that white is better
to maybe play a fault
I don't think that putting this on light
squares is so great you're heading for
the counter play him I'm surprised that
he took why did he take you know I
forgot that that this is the same to be
honest but still check it feels like I
have some counter blame a phone check at
least this was hanging
how to make any headway here maybe I can
try to play from could be three trying
to trap the bishop almost trap the
bishop I can yes 95
yeah yeah okay so let's let's grab that
check
Knight b6
mmm very tricky position now one minutes
left on the clock
night fire from threatening made on f3
hmm maybe you can just take it no
check
and isn't this somehow tricky for if I
go to if I ever manage to go to g5 does
look f3 made I only have 30 seconds left
so no way I'm able to calculate this
time warning there's no mate check check
it's the side seen but not sure it's
helping
only seven seconds
check two seconds a minute you should
draw at least check check okay
at least the draw game come on the
server this is a draw and not some
nonsense well you can construct a made
against this with the civil bishop Wow
very lucky very lucky I think I wasn't
in some trouble I mean it was probably
drifting between okay and and really big
trouble and I know somewhere around here
it felt like I should lose a 92 is
winning of course
no 92 gave me this made I only saw this
later
I played 95 relatively quickly but this
is just just over of course no no this
is my point
check Jim it's not exactly difficult
otherwise it's rook f3 checkmate plus
the rook is hanging of course yeah this
was a win that okay Dwight would have
been quite lucky 193 Oh God 93 ok very
good
I played this one I know I'm just
completely lost again 93 Wow check yeah
now I'm completely toast compass on on
mate already if this is winning for
white with h7 now but he played this
move and of course black is black is
Winnie around around the stage I mean
earlier but no way with the sky
seconds well this was really a bad game
don't hope it's not contagious and
you'll catch some of those blonde
writers all right
thanks for watching